holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] batman
uh welcome the fat man beyond i'm kevin
smith i'm mark bernard
hey ho here we are at the scum and
villainy cantina
you can't move in this place you can't
breathe it's back to the [ __ ] gills
everyone having a good
time because everyone loves a geek bar
and this is everyone's favorite geek bar
right here on hollywood boulevard
hollywood california look at all these
fun people you guys having a good time
yeah pipe in the audience knows they're
jc like we're at an nfl game and we know
nobody's in the stands but we somehow
still
hear a crowd go this is the stanley
kubrick version of the show where i see
an audience that's not there
and they're like of course you've been
here all the time lloyd the ghostly
bartender
will be mixing up your blue what do you
call the bloom blue milk blue milk
drinks
um are you uh how you doing over there
jc just to give you a heads up
jc running solo tonight andrew has the
sunday to enjoy jc
doesn't i oh here he is
i am he's like stop asking me questions
like don't ask me to change the angle of
the camera
there's a lot going on uh it says
hmm we're sending all right he's doing
we're bouncy
we're bouncing we also don't have a shot
of me because there's too much going on
too much going on
i'm gonna try to clean up the stream a
little bit we won't [ __ ] uh be
throwing angles around because there's
one man and and jc's got to control it
all so
i was like hey jc we're not even [ __ ]
cut to him
he's like no what i got no nine things
happening you got no proof of life for
all you know jc is [ __ ] dead and
we're weekend to bernie in this [ __ ]
hey let's go ahead and get a frosty
dickery
um before we we're in a bar we could
literally get a frosty daiquiri
uh before we go anywhere ladies and
gentlemen a little housekeeping
yes sir i have a hot date tonight i'm
gonna get laid so
this show will not have a q a here's the
cue
are you gonna get laid kev here's the a
[ __ ] yeah sooner i get out of here
so and we're seen so
good everybody did you enjoy the show
what show but we have a guest
and we'll be talking to a guest after we
get into the news and stuff like that so
we got a show for you for sure
before we do anything let us take this
moment
to congratulate yes the joker himself
joaquin phoenix mm-hmm just had a baby
yes with you
i mean he's a good actor he ain't that
[ __ ] good yeah no he couldn't
produce a job i mean he could make you
think he had the baby but that's and
then do a little dance at the end
yeah on the staircase and you're like so
dark
he can't have a baby himself but his
fiancee
rooney mara is that her name rooney mara
she just had his baby so they had a baby
i guess
in the parlance indeed hard times um
so i mean it's relevant because he's the
joker and [ __ ] like that but
this is the part that almost made me cry
what did they name the baby
river
it on the glass that almost made me cry
that you [ __ ] guessed it
how beautiful is that that's adorable uh
for those that don't [ __ ] know
because you know you're 12. joaquin
phoenix comes from a family of famous
phoenixes
and long before joaquin was phoenix back
when he was leaf
phoenix his brother river phoenix of
course from stand by me
from sneakers from yes in the opening of
indiana jones he played young india and
jones on the tv but in [ __ ]
glass crusade was it i think is
beginning um and ma
and of course my own private idaho
[ __ ] legend man like a
wonderful wonderful actor and stuff he
named his
[ __ ] kid after his brother he loved
his brother they seemed very tight i
mean i didn't know them and [ __ ] but
like
they seemed very tight from everything i
saw they
like i saw him i met him i think i
talked about at the mercy for animals
gala like right before they announced
right before i think it was right before
joker came out actually
um and uh or part of the run-up to
the oscars yeah yeah it was yeah
i hadn't seen it at that point and i
remember having no because i think it
just come from venice it was before it
came out
if i remember quickly and um you know i
so at one point i was talking to him and
i was like you got
like your whole [ __ ] family was like
famous before i was ever in the business
so that's super famous to me and stuff
and i said and i'm like i love doing
parenthood and [ __ ] like that
but your brother and he talked about his
brother very warmly um so
he named his kid after his brother
that's [ __ ] dope
yeah that's the kind of news that makes
you go yeah
you know people aren't all awful exactly
exactly exactly like you know [ __ ]
maybe we have a constitutional crisis
coming who knows but [ __ ] at least
there's simple beauty in the world like
a man naming his kid after
his decease because there should be a
river phoenix in the world and
we had gone for a long time without one
what kind of writing is this that you're
giving away for
free oh my god say it again there should
be a river phoenix in the world
it's [ __ ] good dude save that for a
script
copyright mark bernard i got that one
good [ __ ] that's a good line if i
heard that on like the boys i'd be like
[ __ ] kripke's good man i say that now
watching the boys you caught up
i'm one episode behind i just watched
friday nights
yeah so [ __ ] good they really showed
their hand at where they're going and
[ __ ]
okay yeah the last thing i got to was
like laser my [ __ ] tits
that was the episode before which okay
superhero sex yeah it was pretty rough
but then in the
most recent episode it's just like they
put it on front street who she is where
she came from blah blah blah
it's uh it's been wonderful um have you
seen this
i haven't seen it yet but i've read
about utopia i
i have not seen it yet it's on amazon
it's on amazon you know what it's about
it's it's got a comic book in it yeah
like it's based on a british
tv series that's about or at least
features a comic book
that can somehow tell the future
and i i just saw this concept and i was
like in a pre-marvel
dc movies world that would have been
like
what a comic book is at the center of
something
like holy [ __ ] well i was heroes right
like when the first one heroes first
dropped it's like wait
what's happening yeah like oh my god
this [ __ ] sounds exactly like
some of my favorite marvel comics i mean
exactly
i mean homage homage or theft you tell
me um
so yeah it this sounds i'm going to
watch the [ __ ] out of this i'm very
curious um flynn
i'm not sure who's i think william is
that the guy the gun girl
um screenwriter um she also
ended sharp objects on hbo this was a
follow-up to that
she's sharp objects honey objects what's
the follow-up
this is that follow-up because she
produced she was the showrunner and
shelf objects and now she's the
showrunner on utopia but they're not
connected they are not connected near as
far as i can tell
so she did utopia the gone girl lady
and it's based on a british thing yes
they still do that where we steal ideas
from the brits
like where all the family came from
where samford and son came from
san francisco is a british show first
yeah we will happily steal the format of
any show that takes place overseas
and import it to the united states yeah
but back in the day when we were kids it
was easy because
nobody saw foreign tv but nowadays it's
like
you could probably watch the british
utopia uh somewhere
yeah it's hard to come by but yeah no we
still
do that kind of he said yeah jc is
behind us i feel like we're at the
cockpit of the moon falcon and han solo
is behind us
he's fixing [ __ ] while while she's going
so what are we doing back there
are we are you having to patch things
are we even online
uh oh bear with us kids jc is working on
it
as you can see look at him running wires
like he was literally up in the rafters
like
yanking cords down
no we're not put that one over there
um you know what i uh did this morning
tell me
what was it yesterday morning maybe it
was yesterday morning
wee hours in the morning i was up and at
like three in the morning i said [ __ ]
i'll grab a smoke
try to go back to bed so i was grabbing
a smoke and i was like what will i watch
because you know you don't want to get
involved in like writing that'll wake
you up and [ __ ]
so i was watching the last harry potter
movie but they split it into deathly
hallows part two
so i watched part one and part two wow
well
i skipped around to my favorite parts of
you but part one then i was like oh [ __ ]
maybe i should go back and watch this
what a mistake my god it's so [ __ ]
like
it's them they're in the woods for over
half the movie
and you know they took the book i know
this is not a hot take or anything
because this happened like a decade ago
but
bring it they [ __ ] split the book
into two movies
and you didn't need it you could have
just made one movie an hour
longer made it a big old fat juicy movie
but like
the woods see sequence goes on and
on and on i couldn't believe it i was
like there were points where i was doing
the
like if fast forwards 10 seconds if you
press this button
because they were doing like a walking
shot where harry is walking from there
to there
and i was like there's no way they're
doing this whole [ __ ] walk cycle and
they did
and i kept fast forwarding and nothing
was said no
no action it was just him walking toward
an object i'm like these guys
what a luxurious edit this must have
been seemed like it was a struggle to
come up with
full content yeah that's one of those
where you can tell like this was not an
artistically motivated
decision yeah no it's an ice cream chuck
outside
jc your phone's ringing
that could be will saying you're not
even online
this is pirate radio version of fat man
beyond ladies and gentlemen who wasn't
this
oh oh boy there's troubles ladies and
gentlemen
uh but yeah both those two harry potter
movies we're very much the
we're going to make as much money as we
can it seemed like a cash grab
very and i can't remember i saw him both
in the theater and i honestly for the
life of me
could not remember any of the details of
part one as i'm watching and i'm like
holy [ __ ] it's like a brand new movie to
me
but it wasn't like what a gift it was
like what a long
[ __ ] movie why are we doing that and
i i could see
i don't remember feeling this but i
could [ __ ] see somebody being like
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me what a
rip-off like
i mean i think they were best parts at
the end with you know spoilers death of
dobby that's
pretty emotional it is i think they they
were they were counting on the fact that
if you were a die-hard harry potter fan
more potter is good potter like if this
is my last gasp at this i want to just
swallow in it for as long as i can
i'm all for it but it's like them alone
in the woods depressed
first it's the three kids and then uh-oh
the cord came out and then the uh
then it's like ron leaves and then it's
just harry and hermione
and at one point they dance and like you
think like oh my god maybe they're gonna
kiss although i never heard about this
in the book or anything
so yeah it's just [ __ ] long man i
mean you know it's all over now they
made all their money and [ __ ] so
i'm not dissuading anybody from saying
it but as i watched it i was like
whoa whoa man i appreciate your sizzling
hot take
thanks man i get around sometimes people
are like how come you're never negative
well there it was
you were there to see it statute of
limitations is up
yes as soon as [ __ ] everyone involved
in the production is dead
then i spilled the tea on how i feel it
uh it is the best take on a movie i've
seen
since there was a comic book resources
article did you catch win of this
where this writer was like oh i figured
out the secret to stanley kubrick movies
he would actually have been a good
filmmaker if only he'd ever come to
grips with his toxic masculinity
and basically that was what was keeping
him from greatness
oh well it's what keeps us all from
greatness apparently and also this guy's
never seen a stanley kubrick movie
because they're kind of all about toxic
masculinity right
like you can't really look at like the
shining or
full metal jacket yeah they're all
pretty toxic dudes or eyes wide
shut and if you ever see that
documentary about the making thing
shining
he was pretty toxic with shelly duvall
totally but yeah to pretend as if he was
a
not a good filmmaker not one of them
yeah
and b this thing that all of his movies
are about is a thing that he's never
reckoned with that that seemed like the
the weakness was the author of this
piece not to be an ageist but
sounds like a relatively young take um
you know
i i don't know said author i'm not even
going to blast him but i mean you could
find the piece it's not hard it was
trending the other day on how bad a take
it was
because everyone was just like are you
crazy dude what did you just discover
things honestly i used to take the
internet so seriously at one point in
the beginning you know because i was on
it when they started it and [ __ ]
i was on it in the days where you could
be like i visited every site on the
internet now
i put my vista to work you guys but um
um [ __ ] what was my point i had a stoner
bump
what were we just talking about uh
discovering things on the internet that
you hadn't
discovered before but what were we
talking about stanley cooper
shitty hot takes yeah you've been you've
been lots of places you've seen lots of
things and yeah i got braggy for some
reason i'm like you know
i was doing a lot of things and then i
got lost in my brain and i forgot the
point i was trying to make
uh oh i know what it is thank you mark i
used to take the internet very seriously
and then one day i saw somebody give a
similar
hot take on quentin tarantino and said
that he was a hack and i'm like
hey man [ __ ] like say you don't like
his movies or whatever but
that guy's a hack like what the [ __ ] am
i
and then i was like i know that guy
ain't a hack i think the whole world
agrees the guy's not a hack
so this person is wrong hence the whole
internet
is wrong is potentially wrong about
things that's when i realized
i ain't taking them so seriously yeah i
am all for the
the a new generation discovering
something yeah
you know like there's there there was a
big ability they [ __ ] discovered
chasing amy and they were like it's
wrong it's bad i was like i'm sorry i
didn't mean it
but uh but you know phil collins is in
the air tonight
oh well those two kids were just like
like it literally started it was like
the top five of itunes sales because
these two black kids who were like you
know twins apparently in their early 20s
have been discovering [ __ ] that they
like we've been told this was good
let's let's not see it beforehand and
watch it together for the first time and
react to it or listen to it yeah they're
all listening they're all
they're just listening to like musical
tracks yeah and they're like we were
we were told this was cool oh [ __ ] and
watching them lose their minds
when the drums and the drum kicks the
way you did when you first heard it
as a kid you're like oh my god it still
works totally so it's
like the the idea of discovering
something for the first time and coming
to art work anew
is not inherently bad right but the
pretending that nobody else had thought
about this like i'm going to give you a
scholarly treatise on what i've
discovered is the flaw in this guy's
filmmaking
also like pretending that the guy wasn't
a great filmmaker
like yeah i think everyone universally
agreed on that right away
yeah i mean whether you like his movies
or not it's like oh clearly this guy was
a master of his form and
pushed the medium in a new direction he
went to space before
[ __ ] george lucas did yeah you know
like i i understand
not great with shelly duvall but you
know apparently an [ __ ] and that's
totally fine but it's the
what slow driver too i always heard
that that right there is a why did it
take us 140 takes to get off of this
exit uncle stanley well he would i read
a story where they were like you know
they're shooting on this location one
road in
one road out and you know as soon as
they were like and that's a wrap for the
day
everyone got raced for their cars
to get out before stanley because if you
were behind stanley stanley did
five ten miles under the speed limit
and so you were [ __ ] you couldn't
just tear ass down the road and [ __ ]
so slow driver slow driver
and that makes you [ __ ] public enemy
number one in my book
indeed so then you [ __ ] with shelley
duvall
that's also terrible so this week's hot
take theater we've decided
[Music]
that harry potter movie was too long and
stanley kubrick wasn't too nice a guy
yeah but like really talented yeah but
everyone knows he's a great filmmaker
and that's fat man beyond you come here
for the hot takes
you're getting them jc are we even
online are we just amusing each other
we're good there it is just keep going
stop talking
he's for a minute i thought we were just
doing a show for him at this point
and it was a weird show because he
wasn't even paying attention no he's
running around i kept on feeling as if
we were always like five minutes away
from sparks in the
in the room and the entire thing going
offline that's true and he's trying to
make us feel good and calm about no no
no
it's all fine nothing's on fire all is
well he's kevin bacon in an animal house
before it gets trampled
um all right what have you been up to
this week anything you got any upfront
[ __ ]
what's on your shirt let me see
flash that's fantastic flash coding how
many people do you have to explain that
shirt to i mean
my wife she was are you serious yeah
she's how wait how old she's our age but
she like she missed the charles grodin
wave really yeah
and i'm like midnight run you got you
nothing i mean this is yeah list goes on
heaven can wait
yeah but you know i incredible shrinking
woman i stand didn't you have cable
that's what i would have said growing up
in a barn
it's an excellent [ __ ] shirt though
thank you splash growth and [ __ ]
um what have you been doing i uh i left
a job this week
you finished up on picard i finished up
on star trek because there was i saw you
tweet about it and then there was some
confusion people like what the [ __ ] did
you get fired yeah are you okay
it'll be all right man you'll recover
from this we finished
because that's you know and it's it's
hard for the
average person who has a normal person
job yeah to understand
like my mom still doesn't quite get it
it's like oh honey are you okay it's
like
this was always gonna happen yeah like
i'm it's a contract it's a term
employment like i'm here for 24 weeks
um 25 if we're doing a rounding error
and and no matter how good and or bad
one does during those 24 weeks
that's the job that's the job so like
yeah no i had a good time i think we did
some good work
um we'll see we're still far from
production because who the hell knows
when we're going to get to shoot
a giant science fiction tv show
but yeah no i clean out my office that i
had visited once
because it was covered yeah like we were
i i was brought on
my first day was like march 4th march
5th
and by like march 10th we were like yeah
no we're uh we're done being in the
office gang we'll uh
we'll maybe see you it was back into the
real world
yeah go right at home we'll see you on
the zooms
yeah that's right it was a zoom writer
room zoom right around widget or zoom
it's it's i don't know how much zoom
zooming you've had to do
at length a bunch in this not in love
with it
no you know like it's i
think it's surprisingly convenient
though yeah no it's it's functional for
a lot of things yeah
but for the for the ongoing creation of
of content not great unless the unless
you just want to make the joke over and
over
jackson yeah if you're rebooting the
jetsons
then it's pretty then zoom is like right
up your [ __ ] alley man
all those zoom jokes all the zoom jokes
but yeah it was it was a
it was a fun room to be in i feel like i
barely got to know the people i was in
the room with
because you didn't have a traditional
room experience yeah like all the time
we were together we were working there
was never any like that
half an hour everybody gets a little
early and hangs out there was never
lunch we talked over there was never
we're gonna go for a walk on the lot
none of that it's here we are well when
you were a kid
and you wished to work on a star trek
show you forgot to add
and i want to eat lunch with everybody
and i want us to be buddies
right you got exactly what you wanted i
really did i forgot no frillies though
i forgot to make it very clear to the
genie yeah the totality of the wish that
i had that's how they get you dude
that's how they'll get you those genies
[ __ ] small print genies
oh it's all about the fine print genies
and devils
the same thing it's all about like you
didn't say
this right um so yeah so i had to go
to get a covet test to get onto the lot
to retrieve my stuff
oh is that right yeah i've had three
since coming back from jersey i had to
get them
or my kid wasn't letting me back in the
house literally quarantined me in my
office my kid was like so hardcore about
about like you know i went to jersey
then i went to florida
and you know i we opened movies and
movies
that was fantastic success in red bank
new jersey uh thanks to the folks
who went thanks to gianni's who hosted
us
and stuff uh but while we're there you
know like the movies out here i took
pictures of people and i felt i was
socially distant
enough probably not you know
as much as one could have been but like
definitely we were on two different
planes and
mostly everyone i was taking pictures
with wearing masks
two people i took a picture with didn't
have a mask
those are the ones the kids saw kid like
sent me a flurry of [ __ ] texts how
dare you you're killing us all you're
gonna put the entire house in jeopardy
the word betrayed was used oh [ __ ]
i was like this kid's real [ __ ] emo
and i was like who's fat who's this
kid's dad
and i remember this could go to the
thesaurus to make fun of him i was like
and also like [ __ ] man like i was just
like why don't you wait to yell at me
until i have coped like you know she was
acting like i came home already with it
and spread it around the house and [ __ ]
and i'm like
don't get mad until like i'm you know
it turns out bad she's prophylactically
chastising you
very much so and like a parent
in a way that i never did with her as a
kid i was not that parent i'm like don't
parent me
so i got three tests i had to get a
rapid results test
well i had to get tests i got to wrap up
results it was negative
then i got the brain tickler and it goes
to a lab negative and then a few days
later i got another brain tickler
went to the lab [ __ ] negative then i
was allowed to
be with others core mingle yeah so
[ __ ]
rude um so you had to take a test just
get on the lot just to get on the lot
you know and and
you get in there and there's just a
pencil in the office you're like [ __ ]
god damn it
um but yeah just to get my little
shopping bag because you know every tv
writer's got their go bag
of like all right here's my pictures in
my family here's my phone charger here's
the mug that i keep all my pens in
and just here i go and here i come
others are way more
highfalutin with like artwork on walls
and like i'm not that guy
no i realize that shocked i'm even got a
mug of pens to be i don't know
right it's a cia mug too does it really
yeah
i got that i mean it [ __ ] works with
pens anymore well i like to do
you go back in time when you're writing
[ __ ] i like to get in a time machine i
like to go back to 14
28. i feel like we're looking in the
future i wish to do so in the past
yes it's called writing not typing
all right um all right well [ __ ]
there you go
man he he quit card space
he said the final frontier and he said
his final goodbye
because they fired him no this [ __ ]
contract was over he's all done
and he got his dream job for a minute he
got to work on some [ __ ] but
i happen to know he's working on other
[ __ ] way more exciting so
your dream job comes oddly enough when
you're
when you've discovered your when other
dreams are coming true
and the dreams are fertilizer for other
dreams yes you must be afraid to dream a
little bigger
and when it rains it pours sometimes
[Music]
don't be too much into that yeah heavens
heaven
so mark bernard's writing storm says
comicbookmovie.com
because kevin smith made a rain pun what
is uh
what does one say congrats on completion
thank you thank you very much
i remember when you got the job and
stuff yeah it's uh
it's it's weird i was talking to tricia
helfer yesterday
um with whom i do the battlestar
galactica cylon herself
cylon herself the numerous six and we
are one episode away from finishing
the show are you [ __ ] me we did the
the penultimate episode
um what is today sunday friday with ron
moore was our guest and i was like i'm
feeling
oddly bittersweet about it because this
will have been
the longest professional initiative i've
ever completed
like i've worked lots of places i've
worked for 12 years
but it's been only for a year two years
or even like i was at ew for 13 years
but the magazine still goes yeah it was
going before i got there oh this is done
when you're done
it's done when i'm done like i will have
ended a thing and
and i think of substance and i've never
done that before
and so this this feeling of huh
it's gonna be over and we got there yeah
we [ __ ] pointed to a place in the
rafters and we hit the ball
and like the show itself you were like
let's find the earth
let's find new earth so it's [ __ ]
dope congrats
thank you never occurred to me to end
the podcast
such a good idea to have a finite like
you know the and here we'll be finished
yeah now and we are coming up on 300
episodes [ __ ]
oh how did that oh us i thought you
meant you guys i was gonna i was gonna
say
we're also coming up on three that's a
great thing right we are right now this
is episode 299
wow next episode which i believe is on
friday
is the 300th episode of fat man beyond
i we should we should throw a party
gotta have some [ __ ] guests right we
gotta pull some guests
shouldn't we get like we should start
[ __ ] hey man give us a
happy 300 episode from a bunch of shout
outs
yeah you know we could
there sounds like there are some
superheroes losing their jobs next year
maybe they'll have time to shout us out
maybe i mean
they might be busy true with human life
young kryptonians that's true man and
that's a a very ham-fisted segue
into the news ladies and gentlemen we
got some news for you mark's collected
some news i see a thick little pile of
news
i do thick luscious pile of news oh yeah
give us the news mark give us the
business i got a 70s bush full of news
right
yeah and this these ain't the days of
[ __ ] virgin smoothies or [ __ ]
landing strips it's growing that [ __ ]
wild
[ __ ] it looks like a goddamn bikini
it's an ewok just hang in between
wicket between your legs wick it in the
thicket
um nub dub yup dubby boppin yup
[Music]
well i was alone out there for a second
i was like did you ever see return of
the jedi
oh my god i got to tell you all about it
it's the third
star wars saga so we're in the sand
we're on the sand we're on a racket but
not really came out third but really
number six
very confusing didn't see that coming um
bears
[ __ ] bears supergirl is taking her
final flight
this of course bittersweet uh but
all good things come to an end and uh
generally these arrowverse shows tend to
tap out
six seven seasons six or seven right
yeah i mean arrow arrow made it to eight
eight eight but uh uh it's a miracle
that
supergirl made it to six considering it
almost died with season one
indeed when cbs was like turns out
mercifully the cw rescued and became a
strong contender i'll be honest with you
working on that show was some of the
best times i've had in my life
professionally and personally i'm so
glad that show exists
i loved it before i directed on it just
as a [ __ ] i was like god
her relationship with her sister is so
beautiful it made me
go like i really [ __ ] up by not being
a girl with a
[ __ ] older sister that would have
been cool yeah i missed out
i mean you have an older sister i know
but like i'm a boy so it would have been
nice if i was a girl and i related to
her like cara
related to to um kyler well that's
another character's name but kyler's
name in real life i think
um yeah i mean you know you kind of
you know gender is a spectrum yeah you
totally could have
that's true but then again that is not
the reason why we're here
such a great such a great show um she's
such a great
person and like honestly the light of
the [ __ ] world
and as a number one on a show who works
literally every day and every scene
because you're the titular character and
stuff
and sometimes they hoist you up on wires
because you have to fly on a green
screen
and when they hoist you up you're up
there for hours and the [ __ ] outfit
you wear
is not comfortable the harness is to
keep you all off
she always has smile on her face always
so wonderful and gracious and stuff
so you know in other news
in conjunction with this they just
announced that they had their kid
yeah uh melissa and christopher wood
our prince adam slash he-man indeed this
is a very incestuous story he's very
close to him
i mean but they just had a little boy
named huxley huxley
adorable so um you know
a lot of people have families and work
and stuff but
you know this timing of this feels real
good
she's going to be able to enjoy the
first
few years of her kid's life in a way she
would not have been able to
if this was season two of supergirl
right you know i mean it's just
because these hours on this show like
are a [ __ ] nut biter not for you know
the director i came and went
but for her you're talking about 15 to
18 hour days
and five days a week and [ __ ] like
that's all the vfx stuff and she's in
almost every scene
yeah and how are you going to do that
and like raise you know [ __ ] kid and
stuff
so it's coming at the right time it's
ending as that part of her life's
beginning and stuff
and she's an amazing actress i saw her
on broadway she did beautiful
the carole king musical so she could be
a broadway kid
she just be in movies now other [ __ ]
tv shows and stuff
she's wonderful wonderful [ __ ]
actress so she's gonna land on her feet
and i think
i don't you know i would imagine she
probably you know got the news like
well you know that's a shame but
all good things come to an i think she's
probably philosophical but i've read her
[ __ ] post she's very
supportive and i also think that like
the news was not a surprise to her
yeah you know like i think that she's
very much in those conversations of like
listen are we coming to the end of the
story like what are you guys thinking in
the writers room because here's where i
am i want to go raise this kid yeah and
so
i don't i don't think it was a a a
judgment delivered to her as much no i
don't think she was like what
yeah like a decision they all kind of
came to together right
and they've had so what next season is
the last and it'll be season six
season six is going to be 20 episodes
and they're starting later
to adjust for her maternity leave as
well as clearly vancouver is just coming
up to
speed on on production you know in in
the covet era they're going to have the
same bumps that we're having
and so yeah starting with her in january
makes some sense because she's going to
want that time
with a kid bummer
beautiful show sometimes on twitter
there's a lot of people who
[ __ ] on the cw [ __ ] shows i you know
they're like
it's not marvel and i'm like it's not
marvel but
it's damn good stuff like on its own i
i've
i loved that show so much and
i'll be sad to see you go i hope to god
i get to direct one of those 20 episodes
you know there's a world where you get
just 20 women directors and
[ __ ] all the dudes for the last season
but if they're letting a dude in there
to go back to national city you know
some folks i do i can make some fun you
can make some phone calls
uh yes there she is right there chronic
in our movie
uh melissa herself i mean a wonderful
woman what that will leave
because they they don't seem to be
generating
berlanti shows at the same rate that
they're losing brilliance let's be fair
they're just
lois and cl whatever they're calling
lois and clark superman and lois or
something that's a new one
right star girl is new star girl is a
new one
um but you know we're we're gonna
we lost arrow we're losing supergirl um
i don't know how much how much gas flash
has in the tank
i mean i think grant will be going for
another year or two for
no other reason than to beat arrow
because i'm sure this will be like hey
how long they go
110 episodes 111 for that
um but like legends i'm not sure you
know
there's always a point at which you know
when when a show launches
to its finale they cross
between terms of um the expense is going
up
and ratings are going down right and
that is always the point after which
it becomes a decision every year to
renew it
and so i don't know if if and also the
model
just doesn't work the way it used to
like you know i i think a lot of
berlanti stuff is
now migrating to hbo max like as we've
seen
you know the titans doing patrol those
are his right
i'm not sure about doom patrol but
titans definitely is um star girl
that's his yeah struggle will premiere
on hbo max and i think
and cw as well but it feels like and
i've you know i think there's some
berlanti stuff
like more superhero stuff going
hbo max i think that you know you'll
start seeing
not like everyone's going there but like
they can get away with
cursing you can do harley quinn and have
everybody you can have the joker
[ __ ] say [ __ ] and nobody bats an eye
so
you know we've seen a lot of the cw
shows it's been almost 10 years
of a model that greg berlanti brought
with him
from dawson's creek so we've seen
nearly a decade of dawson's creek with
masks and
capes and stuff sooner or later that
will
run out of gas so i think you're right
like you know star girl is new
that puts some fresh gas in the tank men
and lois will be new
black lightning probably has another
couple of years left in it if not longer
if they
keep want to keep going with it batwoman
is kind of relaunching
and yeah they show the the picture just
one of davisia and
javicia in the in the costume which is
kind of rad
but yeah it's it's it's a period of flux
i think for the berlanti verse and
whether it's about expanding
or contracting to a good number that
they can sustain whether it's
finding a good again you know place in
the rafters to point to and say we're
going to end it all
there right with some giant crossover
event and that will be the end of the
berlanti verse
i don't know but it's it's it's a it's a
thing i'm sure people are thinking about
i'm glad it existed i got to play it's
fun and it's still going on it's not
like oh and it's all over and [ __ ]
supergirl is done but after next season
but other than that
no other cancellations right now it's
actually you know you can make the
argument like they're strong as ever
but mark raises a good point like you
know if supergirl goes away
next is probably flash and then you know
legends and or black lightning
and and are they replacing these with
anything you got star girl you got
superman
and lois i guess yeah i mean look the
more go away the more
they make room for perhaps new shows
very very true
um all right so we got another year
though to love on
supergirl at the very least um
and back to the marvel part of the
universe
at the emmys on sunday um did you watch
the emmys i did not
um i watched i think i watched most of
it
i hear a lot of my pics won though like
things that i liked yeah did they yeah
like [ __ ] watchmen won
a bunch very happy to see watchmen win
um best writing and
and best limited series and uh i like
succession that won a bunch of [ __ ]
were you a shit's creek fan jennifer is
i i
watched the first three episodes with
her years ago
um when they first aired and you know we
were big fans of
like uh all the christopher guest stuff
so we loved them
and it just didn't click with us when we
were watching i was like oh that's all
right but like never
continued on jennifer recently deep
dived and like [ __ ] loves
the show religiously and keeps showing
me scenes the way i show her scenes from
comic book movies and stuff
so she's a huge fan they won big too
they uh
they they did something of a sweep where
it was best comedy
best writing for a comedy best actor
best director
oh canada oh took all the emmys
um yeah and i i too like kind of slept
on it for a long time and just started
watching it now and like
i i get it i guess jennifer says the
first season is like good but she's like
it really kicks in
and figures out what it is season two
forward or something
yeah you know and i think sitcoms can
get that level of
endurance because they are iterating
pretty quickly you know 22 episodes and
doing 13 like
yeah no by the time you get to the
second season you get it it's harder for
dramas to get that much
rope from an audience like i got to give
you 13 hours of my time before you get
good
as opposed to i got to give you four
hours of my time true
but oh i'm kind of i'm kind of digging
it but during the emmys yes
was the first real trailer for one
division ah
i almost gagged yes and i of course did
not watch it during the emmys but i saw
it online instantly they put it up
online
um holy [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah if this don't
look like house m
i i don't know what it is like i would
not be shocked if the last [ __ ]
like image of the season is her going
well i guess she can't do no more
mutants well i think it becomes
mute where are their mutants yeah more
mutants i'd like mutants please
yeah a lot of plenty of mutants kids
she i'm thinking about it she could
bring her brother back she totally could
in this in this construct in whatever
weird-ass i like it
we don't know anything about it other
than that trailer but it looks [ __ ]
funny
creepy and it does look like like
they're building her up to be the next
big bad
yeah definitely a [ __ ] you know dr
strange right
there's a there's a little easter egg i
suppose i mean i think
it's full of easter eggs but the one
that captivated me was there's a bottle
of wine pouring into a glass
and the label on the bottle of hawaiian
says meson du mapree
and maison in french's house and so it's
house of
mepris house of m is the is the wine i'm
like
oh you [ __ ] you're just doing
it they're hiding some [ __ ]
they're right well should we take a look
at that trailer can we are we allowed to
do this will we get thrown off the
internet if we watch this like we did
with other trailers should we watch it
with the volume [ __ ] down yes [ __ ]
try it
come and get us yeah kids if we get
thrown off the internet it's not
tech problems it's because we watched a
trailer
which i don't understand how other
people do it
yeah yeah we're not allowed to we're not
even watermarking it we're not even just
we need to do funny voices over it like
wow i lost you
oh hello you're gonna find out who i am
vision hello this maximus where are you
i feel
the show's visionary
then i would understand taking us down
off the internet like these [ __ ] are
terrible
oh miss rambo would you like some of my
friends you are
i would watch that trailer where we
basically just do
the [ __ ] adrian fight voice
mrs crookshanks check it out yeah
who uh regina king won regina kim wong
yaya abdullah
he also won for what best supporting
yeah he was so great
he's so awesome um that's so dope man
i [ __ ] god i love that still every
once in a while
i'll roll like the last two episodes on
uh
like in my office as i'm smoking they're
so [ __ ] good
yeah i haven't seen any of it since it
first aired and i think i'm
kind of due it's almost a year it's
magical dude yeah
no not a year well it was last december
is that when they started
yeah oh my god you're right you're right
remember when the world was fine and we
didn't just chill out a lifetime ago
that was i was on tour when it started
mm-hmm
um it was last september and it ended
just before christmas what uh what were
we oh we're about to watch something
but this seems to be an issue moana
we're gonna watch wanda vision if we get
tossed off you know why
blame disney but it was warner brothers
that tossed us off right they were
because of leonard cohen yeah
um what's the song it's like is it
twilight time or some sort of [ __ ] one
of them old-timey songs
yeah i don't i don't recall uh what
sitcoms are being referenced
look donna reed show and like and
bewitched
my three dead there it is there it is um
you know bewitch style like mrs kravitz
this is total bewitch scene right there
um
i mean i like that and then reality
starts trying to creep in
and stuff oh man i would take how long
is this
i would take 10 [ __ ] episodes of her
going crazy
she's a good actress man and uh he's a
wonderful actor and then together
yeah and like her in the classic squad
and this is like
uh catherine han yeah catherine hahn is
playing i saw it was speculated i forget
which name of the character is but she's
a witch in marvel
who's been around forever she's ancient
as [ __ ] white-haired and stuff
but she's straight out the comics as
well um
everyone was ecstatic about vision
wearing you know and her wearing
halloween variations of their costumes
monica rambo
yeah brief shot of wrong how does she
figure into this she wasn't
they weren't even in uh yeah captain
no yeah it's uh it's i think it feels as
it's a mystery
it's a mystery but it's also starting to
scoop up lots of these
part this ephemera from the marvel
universe like kat dennings is in it
playing
um darcy is she from thor from thor
yeah dark world i like this it's getting
i mean look
i was on board anyway i would literally
just watch it if it was a two-hander
of those [ __ ] in a place and she's
slowly melting down like david lynch
style
that that looks fantastic and it's
coming this year
it is coming this year i think it's it's
sort of slotting before after the
election
i think after the election so something
to look forward to
i think we we get mandalorian before the
election and we get one division after
the election
oh oh all right all right that'll help
oh
more like that more like that make me
feel good that's going to be awesome a
little something there's a future there
to look forward to
yes and i mean there's more of a future
on the disney plus because now [ __ ]
nick fury is getting into his own tv
show
what yes jackson a no-brainer though by
the way
i mean and is it set in the present or
is it all across his career so they can
have young
nick fury as well it is uncle young
expensive nick fury
young expensive i mean any way you cut
it it's expensive nick fury because
you've got sam jackson in a tv show
um but it's there's no information
whatsoever on when it's taking place
except for the fact that last we saw
nick fury
he was on a scroll in space yeah in
space
and if you wanted to be setting up
something like secret invasion
um where the skrulls are coming to earth
to take over
everything this would not be the worst
way to start setting it up
i like it you know but i also do want to
see like nick fury not just
in deep space with skrulls was he an end
game
um at the funeral that's it that's it
so technically that happened
when does captain marvel happen before
that or after that or the p.s scene in
captain marvel
when they showed him no when did they
show him in space it wasn't captain
marvel
um i think it's infinity war
[ __ ] jc tell ask the chatroom
when what the post scene
the post-credits scene with nick fury in
space which movie was that
no that must be no it's not it's not
captain marvel because he's back at his
desk yeah yeah
and the ps on that one is
oh no is it guardians too oh
spiderman far from home far from home
that's because that because it was
we thought it was nick the whole movie
and then it turned out to be the scroll
right and then their post scene was nick
in space
what a weird that are we sure that's
good that sounds right yeah
and then so that was after they put up
that jay jonah jameson scene
mm-hmm yeah jay joner jameson has had
that because there was no post scene in
infinity war
everybody just died right and that was
it
no there was there was the captain
marvel plug in infinity war right
it's when everybody disappears and you
see the glowing beeper
so in continuity the last place we saw
nick fury was the funeral
yes which presumably could come back
from space to do that
right look set it anywhere you want i'm
on board for
more marvel tv because that wanda vision
show
looks fantastic are we going to talk
hellstrom or no
uh i didn't watch the trailer i did
looks great it's a sad
reminder that like that era is over yeah
like because that's from old marvel tv
jeff that's all jeff loeb jeff lopes
version
and so like even if this show is like
[ __ ] brilliant and it looks fantastic
trailer looks really good
one and done you're gonna watch the
season and they're finished and that's
that
right i mean unless there is absolutely
the world in which kevin feige could
really like it
and you know it's on hulu which is part
of the disney family it's not on netflix
so there's no
internal conflict with it look at me i'm
all like it'll never
happen done he's like well what if kevin
buggy like then it will
happen um but yeah i
i i'm excited for for the the tv
universe of marvel to expand
if halstrom can figure into it great
whenever we get to see whatever they
shot from captain marvel i mean captain
america there's a shot of uh
sebastian stan wearing a new
leather outfit that seems to be his new
outfit and
yeah in the show so they're they're
they're shooting there was he was
surrounded by fbi people
today and some pictures of gun on the
internet yeah and it is clear that they
are they are john hammonding this and
they are sparing no expense yeah
like whatever that oh these are movies
there's these they're not they don't
have tv show budgets they're making many
features
yeah i mean six or one big ass [ __ ]
feature eight episodes 200 million
dollar budget just broke it into chunks
like there's that's schneider cup money
yeah because the segway we can
absolutely segue into snyder cup money
because
apparently reportedly the budget on the
snyder cut
now hold on i'm going to put a pin in
what you know
and take us back to what we knew when
they first made this announcement
they said no more than 20 million would
be spent right so
yeah 20 30 million dollars to like
finish some effects which i was like you
know what but
like franklin why not roll expensive but
yeah absolutely
um to do some select reshoots um how
much is it now uh
reportedly grand total is grant weld is
not even potentially the grand total but
according to the rap the the justice
league
zack snyder cut version the budget will
be about 70 million dollars
which is the whole ass new movie the
second season of game of thrones cost 70
million dollars and they made eight
episodes of those
whoa and so this isn't reshoots
this is apparently there never really
was a snyder cut
there was some footage shot there was a
lot of a lot of footage
but you could there's a lot of like
animatics
stuck in to finish telling the story um
and it was
i it there it was not like here's a dvd
copy of the snyder cup but there was a
watchable version of that movie that he
had
but a lot of it is ex from what i heard
ex ex
expository cards to describe what was
missing
right which apparently is 70 million
dollars worth of
right i mean footage so yeah there there
was probably a dvd you could watch
um or no no i think there was you had to
watch it at his place
right but and he probably was part of
the movie
not on screen but sure there was
exactly like pausing it to be like okay
and now we would do all this
and blah blah blah okay and now this but
yes was there ever a
like beginning to end snyder cut that
you could pass along on a bootleg
i don't think so i think there was lots
of watchable
footage and big chunks of text or
animatics and also held together with
some narration not in the actual movie
but in the room
whoever you're showing it to be like
okay then this happens because
the way i remember the story is they
didn't get to shoot everything that he
wanted to shoot
oh no no no yeah it's it's it is kind of
clear that what existed for executives
to say
no no okay let's invest in this was a
a presentation more than it was a movie
yes um
and so maybe it was the use of the term
reshoots
because 70 million dollars worth of
reshoots is you're
shooting a movie yeah you're not
reshooting very much of anything
how much were the reshoots the real
reshoots on justice league the joss
whedon ones yeah i think those were
something like 50 60 million dollars i
think roughly around the same price
which i would not be surprised
thematically
you know this this uh
you know this this cut is a purging
um and he's zach's going to make the
movie he wanted to
make and not using the damn frame of the
other stuff and whatnot so
you know if you knew that they gave that
guy 50 million
to remake your movie
it was a school of thought where you're
like well i'll take 70 to [ __ ] put it
back you know what i'm saying
um which i would respect on a certain
level like for him i mean
it's all that makes me happy for him
because what a bad year that guy had
when justice league happened yes like
[ __ ] historically over-the-top ad not
just professionally but also personally
and he's getting his dream come true he
gets to do it this thing was
willed into existence by [ __ ] fans
like
you know probably more than him probably
all the chatter the [ __ ] billboards
the sky writing and [ __ ] whatever
finally connected and he he used that as
fuel and stuff so
it's very rare i can't think of another
example of this story
no no neither can i
for any number of reasons no um but it's
it is it is a landmark moment in cinema
history
um it has almost little dude cinema has
everything to do with
hbo max every everything dude hbo max
and whether it's a tv show it stopped
being a movie because he's making it a
four-part tv show
yeah i mean it's not tv show four-part
streaming event
indeed you know and i guess if it's 70
million
is the new budget for this they would
need according to uh to the rap
to get around 4.66 million new
subscribers
just off of having the justice league
snyder cut
that seems like a doable number right
what are they up to right now
uh i'm i'm not sure i think there's
somewhere around the 12 15 million
subscribers it's just it's relatively
new so they're still building it up
but i uh that's that is a leader you
know
who signs up for what or why like what
if they got formula
and subscriptions but they they were
like uh oh you must like the justice
league and they're like the justice what
now
yeah like you could just be like hype
like i heard about [ __ ]
you know raised by wolves or i want to
see lovecraft country which by the way
continues to dazzle yeah i don't know
it'll be hard to understand or to even
granulate
where these new subscribers are coming
from beyond some kind of survey but
you're not going to survey all 4.6
million new subscribers
so i don't know it uh but there's a
number now there's a shoot for
you can you can try and hit getting you
know
four and a half million people and then
that justifies all of this
it does and even if it don't it's like
lost leader marketing costs essentially
a lot of people are going to become
aware of hbo max because of
the snyder cut so
is also not including whatever
promotional marketing they're going to
do
to remind you in a year that the
snapchat is coming out
that's true the marketing cost will be
so yeah like listen it's
it's a thing that's going to happen it's
a thing that happened because fans
wanted to see
this legendary and apparently fictional
snyder cut
now be wheeled into existence and so now
it is so we're going to see it
we're getting fictional no more now it's
real as raincoat
indeed um elsewhere in the dc extended
universe
there's gonna be a peacemaker tv show i
saw this this week
um smart play i think so very
especially like you know getting the
word out earlier they're like boy this
suicide squad movie's so [ __ ] good
we're already green light a show about
prequel peacemaker tv show
every episode written by james gunn and
he's charming as [ __ ]
your lead or john cena yeah i think
that's
that's a big reason why it's a driver
yeah because a
john cena is incredibly popular but b
he's apparently very good
and dc and warner brothers execs were
like oh [ __ ]
we could do a show on that guy let's do
a show on that
and james already wrote them all james
lockdown
yeah like hey i got nothing else to do i
know
i'm in posting maybe post is done on on
i wish i had that kind of power where
you're making a big movie and then
you're like i want to do a tv show the
big movie they're like okay i always had
that kind of okay james power that he's
got
yeah whatever i like that okay jj power
okay jj yeah what do you need pal
i'm glad this thing [ __ ] exists man
first charlton character to get his own
[ __ ] tv show no
um ain't been no blue beetle show
uh-huh ain't never been no yeah
question show question continues to
confound
elude us indeed yeah this is the first
time a charlton character no captain
adam show the first time a charlotte
character has received a show yeah
whoever created this character is like
[ __ ] a man finally
um but yeah and and it also is a bit of
a
of a of a continuation of hbo max's
desire
to spin off the movies into tv and
you're going to get a
the gotham city sort of gotham pd show
spinning out of the batman you're gonna
get a peacemaker show spinning out of
suicide squad like it's smart i like
their plans
i want to watch their shows it's very
very smart
um let's see what else we got elsewhere
there's a lot of dc eu news
okay um black adam the rock has
announced that they have cast
their hawkman the rock made an
announcement today a huge announcement
yes the rock the rock's announcing some
[ __ ] the rock the rock dude
seven minute announcement about like i'm
back in biden harris yeah he will
happily put on he never did that before
he's never he's never endorsed anybody
um she will happily put on the tightest
sweater known to man
i saw that i mean i saw him looking at
that gun is that how he normally dresses
i mean how about a hoodie or something
like just something a little looser
hockey jersey i mean
this thing was clinging it's clean
it's just like dude come on you can see
every ripple and [ __ ] everything every
vein
it really we didn't like it because it
made us feel self-conscious yeah i mean
i suppose if i also had a ferrari i
would want to polish it and show it off
to everybody also
yeah but like dude i wear layers because
i have undulating flesh
he is tighter than a drum so naturally
he's saved something for every night
and also why do you need to wear a
sweater it's los angeles in
still summer styling he's got he's got a
wife and she was like put a sweater on
he's like i will
eventually that's why all of us wear
sweaters are you cold
the rock because we're told somebody
told us but yes
he both announced that aldous hodge
would be playing carter hall the hawkman
um and aldous is great alice has been
great for a long time he was an
invisible man
yeah he was in hidden figures
i first found him in leverage which was
a fantastic
show from the the i don't know tnt
people the tnt
characters wanted oh my god their
marketing work
somewhere a tnt marketer who came up
with that slogan is like
i knew it we got it you guys
um he was m.c ren and straight out of
compton
well like he's been he's been banging
around for a while and for him to
to hop in and play the the the
thunegarian hawkman
the first well how many times have we
seen hawkman and tv
or anything um did they ever do them on
yeah they did them on the legends
i think um that's right that hawk girl
that hong kong man yeah he showed up for
a bit um i think first
cinematic hawkman though well no i think
you had a hawkman in uh in smallville
no cinematic oh cinnamon big screen big
screen hawkman's big screen debut
yes um and what he's uh what's their
relationship in the comics they fight
um they fight they fight right they
fight
uh i i am not sure i am not a deep
hawkman uh
person um nor am i a deep black adam
person i know a couple of blind spots
for me there got no blind spots for me
but
[ __ ] it i i like i like the rocks
and also like [ __ ] it's it's thanogar
like you get to pull in that entire
mythology and [ __ ] like that i'm i'm all
for it
yeah so that's super cool and he's a
great actor so [ __ ]
very much so you know and and of course
the rock when announcing [ __ ] is never
overly shy about it
so like on his instagram post it's like
so here's the transcript of my call with
alice hodge telling him that he got the
role
he's like hey ellis it's dj because
apparently he doesn't call himself
dwayne he called himself dj
is that i saw somebody say something
about dj and i'm like what does that
mean
but i guess that's dwayne johnson yeah
and uh because he likes to deliver this
kind of news personally is he a producer
on the movie
yeah he is his seven bucks entertainment
he's treating this one [ __ ] seriously
he wants to play black adam in such a
big bad way and has wanted to for like
a long time yeah and so i feel like he's
wholeheartedly just wrapping his arms
around it
that's awesome that he welcomes dude to
the cast yeah that's kind of sweet
um what else we got man he's good people
uh the boys which uh you know wonderful
show so good it's getting a spin off in
is getting a spin-up set in a superhero
college
which a man sounds perfect [ __ ] right
away i was like what
why is it can i watch it now such a
great idea
is crushing it with that [ __ ] show
set and america so damn watchable
i know some people are pissy that
they're only doing an episode a week but
i i it's [ __ ] it's great i will take
it and then it'll be [ __ ]
fun and and always a visual somewhere in
the show where you're like
i never saw that coming yeah i'm one
episode shy
wait until you see this week's episode
this week's like what the [ __ ] moment is
uh
how do i involves a
let me see how can i what can i
it's thick with two c's
ooh it's a stick
spoiler spoilers it's a dick yeah you
got to see it it's kind of like as i was
watching i was like man
did they do that in the comics it
sometimes feels like they're just like
look we got license to go crazy let's do
whatever [ __ ] we want yeah
like if it's not cool what's the point
yeah
it's they're it's cool everything they
do in that show i'm like right on and
really great acting
across the boards great cast i mean
anthony stone is still she's
good [ __ ] phenomenal yeah um
spellbindingly good but even um you know
the less
showy roles like [ __ ] dennis quaid's
kid meg jack wade
so [ __ ] good like absolutely lovable
man you can plug that guy into some
other [ __ ] too
yeah um he's
he's great in the show but like they
should they should put him in other
things
yeah there was a there was a quote a
tweet that i quoted
um from jmd matthias
who was like go with me for a minute but
you know who should play
[ __ ] craven the hunter carl urban and
he just puts up a picture of him
as a as butcher he's like that's [ __ ]
craving it's true
i mean we all got uh what's his name on
the brain um
jason momoa right yeah but
that could be a [ __ ] yeah that would
work because he's [ __ ]
imposing i mean he's also a great actor
he's like remember how [ __ ] good he
was in the thor movie where you're like
holy [ __ ] and he was a great guns dez
and troy
i got them in tech sauce um and and
they're doing a heartbreaking little
story line with him
this season too yeah it's uh it's all
tragic craving be good
but i i am down for this college
spin-off [ __ ] yeah
sign me up hell yes
um black widow is moving um as
is everything good from 2020. yeah the
uh
tenet experiment uh or experiment
as some people say uh did not go as well
as they'd hoped
that was that was like he'll save us
yeah and
it's made something like 280 290 million
here it's only made
41 million which is you know yeah not
what they needed not what they were
hoping they were hoping for that on the
first friday
yeah as opposed to the entirety so based
on that they're like we ain't [ __ ]
other studios are like ah we'll take a
pass we'll see in 2021
yeah so black widow finally did what we
all expected
they would do and moved still not
[ __ ] bending a knee though they're
still not like ah we'll put it on disney
plus
yeah because i think the mulan
experiment similarly was not
as overwhelming is that right i mean it
did well like it made some 265 million
dollars
in literally just the disney premium
downloads which is not bad
for two weeks of release but
you know that is not a number that will
continue to rise i don't think they
think
as opposed to the movie goes its moment
right like and if you can watch it over
and over again there's no like let's
pony up another 30 bucks and watch it
again true whereas if you had a kid who
loved that movie
you were going to see that thing four or
five times true this so
i think they've they've discovered where
and maybe milan was just supposed to be
the the bellwether
the canary in the canary nicole to say
hey
if we release a 200 million movie on
disney plus
how much money will we get back for it
and
i guess they learned and it's not enough
yeah they're like oh it's good but like
we can make a lot more at the box office
right
i mean they make billions of dollars
with these flicks yeah
you know so and and i think that you can
still
piracy will be an issue but sure they
could still release in theaters overseas
oh yeah but if it's already out then we
got it
then we got it so i think they feel that
black widow
anything like live action theatrical
that is not based on a kid's property
it will be hard to earn back that money
uh it's pushing back the eternals
and shang chang chi yeah everything just
sort of slides back
so now like black widow shifts from
november to may 7th to
2021 and then that shifts marvel's
eternals from february 12
2021 to november in chiang chi damn
to july it's yeah
it's a whole it's a whole thing and 20.
man keeping me from my marvel movies
2020 will be the first year since 2009
without a marvel movie in it
there's everyone's looking for the
bottom of 2020
there it is no marvel movies no marvel
movies even marvel movies got chased out
of 2020 it's such a bleak [ __ ] year
yeah man it is not not nearly as rosy as
one might have hoped
20 21 2021
but i mean november is still you know
like you get a bond movie
at the end of november you get in
december
we're gonna get [ __ ] coming to
america too yeah
all right i'm back dune and wonder woman
are all in like the last two
they haven't moved that yet they haven't
moved it since the last time they moved
it because i think they're still open
they're still hoping they might but now
that black widows move they might be
like
i don't know what maybe coming to
america i can't wait man
no um all right what else we got uh the
last news story we have
um which you know it's always the like
let's bring it down for a little bit oh
here it is kids
i'm about to go to the quiet storm
moment of the show
something sad is about to happen the
quiet storm is not the sexy
good point nothing sexy is about to
happen kids soft and warm the quiet
storm
all right
[Laughter]
quiet storm you don't remember that i do
remember that that was the wbls
soft and warm the question the quiet
storm the greatest sexy sounds of r
b um all right so rather than the quiet
storm
this is the cooldown corner that's like
an angry kid
popped up on ovaltine and cheez-its this
is the get in the angry
i know what it is this is the
long-distance dedication
remember on american top 40. bring it
down he'd be like so casey
would you please play ain't nothing
gonna break my stride
to remind me of my grandmother who died
in traffic
well okay yeah here jessica
here's your long-distance dedication um
all right so what happened
our long-distance dedication is to rob
cobb the cartoonist and back to the
future delorean production designer
has died at the age of 83. now this is
the gentleman that designed
the flying uh delorean yes he did not
actually design
a time traveling right he didn't design
the delorean yeah that was a guy named
john delorean yes he was like i got an
idea for a car and i'm going to spend my
fortune making it and nobody will buy it
um he did and other things he's a
fascinating life there's a great
documentary
there is indeed um but he did he he put
the cuisinart in the back and
the flux capacitor and all of that [ __ ]
like he he
created the look of the look of the
device or doc
browns rather indeed um he also
made me mistake that'd be a good game
show question like
what was marty mcfly's car
in back to the future and then you would
of course
say the delorean yes but they'd be like
that was not marty mcfly's car no that
was doc brown's car martin mcfly's car
at the end of back to the future is that
[ __ ] truck thing
yeah like bronco that he was super
excited if that was a final jeopardy
question
everyone loses no way anyone [ __ ]
thinks that deep
totally like marty mcfly never took
possession the title transfer was never
made
mental preparedness mark i'm ready you
are ready for you
can't [ __ ] you can't get me on no
devil's deal of a back to the future
question i know
it was not his car this that's my hot my
third hot take of the night
the fly the [ __ ] time traveling
delorean did not belong to marty mcfly
belong to doc brown
if this was the movie this right now
would be your version of rosie perez
getting foods that begin with
cue the final jeopardy
what's a quince alex
i forgot about that scene that's so
awesome so yes you get to be like a
back to the future trivia and then
somebody would be like well technically
i believe
doc brown gave marty the time
machine he gave him the delorean right
because he had to go find it in a cave
use this to find me and [ __ ] yeah but
that's not till three
but but he did give it to oh good point
so i [ __ ] win on
they try to get me on a technicality but
as i'm the alex chebreck has i said back
to the future nobody said part one two
or three
you gotta specify alex yeah judges and
they're like [ __ ] him i'm like just what
they said [ __ ] you
i would like i would like this scene
also for the you ever see that that um
who wants to be a millionaire bit where
like the first guy to win a million
dollars
is like i'd like to use my phone a
friend and he's at the miller million
dollar question
and he picks up the phone he's like hi
yeah dad uh yeah
you're my phone a friend i don't need
your help i just wanted to call you
right now to tell you that i was going
to win a million dollars
and like hangs up the phone and says
seize the final answer and he wins a
million dollars and it's like
the most dick slash baller move ever
that's pretty awesome yeah it's like
phone a friend not dead i don't need
your help
i know the answer i just want to call
and tell you that i just won a million
dollars
that's good tv you remembered it that
was good
i remembered it but yes it's been a
great story though if you [ __ ]
[Music]
oh my god dad
i should have asked you a question good
for him man
um but he also contributed to e.t raise
the lost ark
um sound political what do you do for
e.t
what do you do for you this cobb guy
i don't know what he did for each other
there you go i don't have specifics
he did un untold things for e.t yes he
did help construct the iconic moss
eisley cantina oh
what a shock did he where i mean the
place we're in right now
i know oh it's a little something to
cobb this is a
some corn on the cob right here indeed
off the cob he created one of its
alien patrons moma nadan
hammerhead hammerhead one of my favorite
action figures of all time one shot in
the movie he's so memorable yep
um he also helped he was a concept
artist on alien
he was production design credits also
included conan the barbarian
and raiders that is strength boy that
is power um he also uh his most recent
projects included southland tales
firefly and the sixth day i was on south
atlanta i know i figured you would be
interested um wow look at that man we
crossed the paths professionally i saw a
lot of his work and appreciated a lot of
his work
i had no idea we could cross paths
professionally he probably designed the
room i was
sitting in with with just to bring it
all
full circle dj dj himself
dwayne the rock johnson i acted with him
there's a [ __ ] trivia question
there's your [ __ ] final jeopardy
um did you people like what what is the
final step
i don't know some question like did who
was kevin smith's cameo role
yes in a movie yeah kevin smith obscure
cameos i'll take uh
obscure cameos for 2000 alex
he fell asleep during the shooting of
the scene with dwayne the rock johnson
in southland tales who is
curtis armstrong no i'm sorry not booger
he was awake the whole scene yeah who is
matthew modine we're looking for kevin
smith
who so close i love king of queens
um wow this dude passed and that dude
passed um it's a bummer
i did great work and we all enjoyed it
indeed i kind of wanted to bring it
around to a vin diesel dropping a music
single
yeah but uh i'm singing he's sang a song
i mean of the celebrities cutting
singles it is
i think my least favorite everyone else
is doing it
i mean i don't know who presently is
doing it my favorite is still eddie
murphy party
time which the internet just discovered
the young internet just discovered this
did you know eddie murphy
did i know i bought the [ __ ] album of
course i knew
because my girl wants to party all the
time party all the time
party all right i don't understand it
why you want to hurt me
after all of the things well done oh my
god i don't even hear it with you
speaking it
because i'm so used to girl i don't
understand it
why you wanna hurt me he could get a
high [ __ ] voice going oh yeah
and then like rick james uh the music
video is maybe one of my favorite things
rick james
yeah like and there's this bit we're
like my girl wants to
but he's like yes bring it in with muffy
junior
he's producing that's how you produce
you do a lot of hand work you do a lot
of like a good job
whole thing's a hand job um
wow man uh that's all the news we got
that is all the news we got it's all the
news we got so jc
we're ready if if our guest is ready
to uh speak to our guest to join the fun
i think he's ready too jc bear with us
folks jc running this whole
funky operation by himself
yeah we could talk up our guests you let
us know when you're ready um
yeah i'm here
well i hear somebody is that you what's
up
there he is ladies and gentlemen give it
up for the great ryan leibowitz man well
you know him you love him
he's he is the gold in golden apple
ladies and gentlemen
uh how are you sir i really appreciate
that intro hi
mark hey hi kevin what's up guys
how are you i'm i'm gonna be a dad right
now
and say a dad thing you're you look like
your dad
you're starting to look like pops
obviously you're gonna take that as the
biggest compliment a huge
compliment for those who don't know
ryan's dad created and mom created
golden apple how many years ago
uh 41ish at this point we celebrated our
40th last year when it came on your show
yeah it was the 40th so 41 years ago man
that was at a time when like nobody was
opening comic book stores
and for for most of my life they were
the world's most famous comic book store
whenever they did a story about anything
remotely comic related which in 1989 was
all about of course batman yes
they would go to golden apple to shoot
remotes and talk to
ryan's dad and stuff um so you guys been
around for a red hot minute
and uh you moved from one location right
now you're still next to gallery in 1988
correct
actually they moved down a little bit
down the street they were directly next
door
that's right across the street and now
they're a little bit farther down i saw
you talking to jensen yesterday
i did i did a lot of walk through with
uh they did a mall rat
show and so we did it on instagram 25th
anniversary
mall rats art show i saw the pieces
i'm sure you bought a few of them
because that's i i did already put in an
order for some and i'm actually gonna go
walk through the room and be like
i'll take that i'll take that and do
some shopping on the wall
so basically you're you're showing a lot
of love to the melrose
avenue merchants this week and i really
really really appreciate it oh my god
and how is
uh how is being a merchant on melrose
these days
i mean that's that's actually one of the
main reasons i i reached out to mark and
you
and jc to come on the show is kind of
talk about the state of the industry the
comic book
that's true this is a show that's all
about you know comic book ephemera and
comic book movies and
tv shows but we rarely talk about comic
books themselves man so this is a golden
opportunity to talk about the bedrock
of all the [ __ ] that we love the actual
brick and mortar uh
organizations uh corporations little
businesses
that sell the pamphlets that we call
comic books
how is it going out there that's the
thing is like comic book stores
in your local you know town are all run
by mom and pop
you know it's all person personal
people like myself and and families
these aren't big corporations these are
even if there's multiple stores in a
certain city
there's still a dude like me a woman you
know running these behind the scenes and
it's
it's been tough gavin like covid was
[ __ ]
ridiculous we were closed for three
months at golden apple
and that's in la proper you know where
you know gavin newsom just said shut it
down
and we closed the doors put
posters up on the windows so nobody
would come in and loot the place
and i was in there almost every day
working my ass off
um and were you guys were you guys doing
like
uh fulfilling orders like do you have
subscription services but can people
still pick up their books in the early
days
yeah so um you know they cut off like
curbside
pickup early they were like no no no
contacting
contact lists everything like we
couldn't even do curbside
i mean i even got a call from like the
dea
like saying i heard you're doing
curbside you can't do that anymore
we said okay we'll shut it down so like
it was
we couldn't open the doors we couldn't
do curbside but we had subscription
customers because as you know in the
comic book industry people subscribe to
to spiderman and batman the same way you
subscribe to people magazine or time
magazine in your home
we keep a box for them in the store
right that's like classic
comic book you know retailing 101 so
we still had to fulfill that so we
brought it all to my house my wife
my mother sharon as you know um
literally called all of our customers
from our house shipped them from our
house fulfilled him from our house
did everything we could but the problem
was there weren't any new comics being
yeah that was that was the other the the
other big part of the problem was there
was no
merchandise to then because right i'm in
shock everyone diamond shut down
everyone stopped
making stuff and in the comments because
three months out and stuff so once those
books were done
there was no new books coming behind
them not only the distributor shutdown
which at that time was there was only
one it was diamond as we just mentioned
and then
the shipping companies shut down because
of covid and the publishers shut down
because of covid
and it was just we were just sitting
there but you know we ended up doing
in a lot of stores and a lot of a lot of
other places is not just about golden
apple
is we started pre-selling books that
will come out we started doing
variant covers that were you know big
you know title books that are going to
come out
several months from now that have been
delayed and that was just a big key to
to our online success so
in store flat just flatlined completely
but online basically blew
up um you know because everybody
couldn't go to their local store so they
started looking online to see where they
could buy things
and we had a really nice website and and
we were really you know
um big on social media and we just
pumped new product and we got a lot of
orders that backed up for months and
months and months
and were you still fulfilling all those
orders out of the house
oh my god yes uh saturday i
packed a hundred orders myself with my
wife at the house like it's crazy like
we have a lot of orders to fill we're a
little behind we've hired more people
we actually are going to be renting a
new facility
over in l.a like a 5 000 square foot
warehouse that we're going to be
doing stuff because our online just
jumped up it's just blown up at this
point so crazy
yeah so it's not all doom and gloom like
yes the store was closed for three
months
yes coveted impacted us so much and and
the rules and regulations like
we still keep limited hours most shops
do 12 to 5
monday through saturday you know we're
normally 11 to 7 or 10 to 9
like we keep very limited hours we have
sneeze guards
on the entire cash wrap and in the back
counter you can't even interact with us
masks are required we have our own masks
with our own logos on them
it's a crazy retail world right now it's
like
it's insane but online is has been great
i mean if anybody's listening right now
that the collector
you know an artist like peach momoko
will resonate to them like to you guys
you're like what the [ __ ] did you just
say
peach what what the [ __ ] are you talking
literally what i was just thinking
who is this this japanese
amazing female artist has just taken the
world by storm and we had
we were lucky enough to work with her
during the kovid
shutdown and had several exclusive
variant covers from her
as you remember the variant cover market
back in the back in the 90s and stuff
like that that's real now like that
the collector market is so strong right
now
there are books that come out this week
that are selling for 20
on ebay that it's just insane what's
happening and that's because stores are
closed because like
i think a lot of it has to do with
stores there's limited access
to physically walking into a store and
getting the books
so everybody's kind of gone online i
think the generally speaking the order
numbers are down the print runs are down
for
second third fourth printings of books
and
also limited edition variants like like
we do so much so it's just been insane
but plus if you're keeping up on the
news which i'm sure you have because i
know harley worked for dc
all the crazy layoffs at dc comics yeah
uh idw like it's just insane and then dc
started to distribute their own books
right thank you yeah what is diamond
so they're out of diamond now 100
percent
yeah when you say they distribute their
own books they are now their own
distributor
no they they found a couple golden
apples of the world
uh midtown comics so they're using
retailers
as the distributors they are which the
the two kind of biggest retailers
um as far as volume as i understand it
and their sales figures and their
warehousing
they took on they said hey we'll we'll
distribute for you you know [ __ ] diamond
so they tried it they went rogue
and this is where we're getting our dc
product from now on so it's it's the
wild west right now guys and it
but we're getting our product we're
getting in a timely manner
we got new comics on the shelf every
wednesday and
you know we're back into full swing and
you know
it's just still so hard with the covet
environment with the
the masks and the social distancing it's
i mean we have a comic we sell comic
books right you want to [ __ ] touch
them yeah it's tactile that's part of
the experiences
put them in a bag and a board read them
if you wanted
something else you'd buy digital comics
right kev exactly exactly
the idea of walking into the store uh
being able to sift through and find the
perfect
unbent copy bring it up to the register
i remember so many times
the guy fantasy zone in red bank that
doesn't exist anymore the old comic book
store
uh the guy who ran the desk was dave
windorff he was the lead singer from
monster
monster magnet
when dave was just a long-haired guy at
the counter and stuff and i would
go through and find my [ __ ] pristine
copies
bring him up and then as dave you know
and he's a big comic book fan
but he didn't fetishize the books and
stuff like i did so
i put my pile down all gently and then
he'd pick him up and like do this [ __ ]
where you're like
we're bending him and i was like can you
can you not
do that and he was like oh you're one of
them
like we have so many customers that
still do that and and
god love them kev like got like [ __ ]
we love bomb on them we let them
spend extra time we let them look
through the whole stack of books
because that's the thing it's a
collector's market and it's so strong
right now
um you know we're just expanding right
now we're also
trying to deal with the fact that we
normally are known for doing signings in
our store like
yeah you guys did 30 years
i've done a signings you've done
signings there i
did my first signing ever comic book
signing was it
golden apple and stuff didn't you meet
your wife there my wife popped in to see
me
so they wrote an article for usa today
ben we were there at the signing
there's a picture of me on my wall in
golden apple
from the usa today sitting next to
marilyn gigliotti from that
signing so that was just me they have
they've had the
i mean this was the store
in hollywood so any time you had famous
people
wanting to promote something in the
comic book world easy but even
celebrities and [ __ ] like remember john
singleton was there and stuff
yeah john oh god john such a such a good
guy
you know god rest his soul he used to be
a weekly guy he would come in
every week we would bring books to his
house or send them to him on set if
you know he couldn't make it in i mean
just you know people love their comic
books you know we do that so what do you
what do you guys so what do you what uh
what's your initiative what are you
doing right now
we're doing like what we call private
signings so like we have a big one
every year we have john carpenter fellow
filmmaker and composer
hardly a fellow filmmaker more like
master filmmaker
he's done a few a few good movies right
yeah
so we do us for last seven years we've
had john and his wife sandy
in and so this year we said what what
the [ __ ] are we going to do with this
kobit world but we're going to doing it
virtually so we're also we're going to
set up a zoom call like this where
fans who buy the book can uh interact
with john and sandy and the
contributors to the to the book it's
like halloween anthology but they're
also going to get pre-signed books
so we send the books to his house he
signs them
they come to the store and then we're
going to do something a little more fun
to make it more interactive where we
have
golden tickets you know uh silver
tickets and bronze tickets as you can
see
willy wonka is kind of a mentor to me
right i think
a real gold ticket behind me well not
real but you know
movie real i see oh no i'm still trying
to figure out if that's a streets of
fire gold cassette
[ __ ] yeah it's a streets of fire damn
right there
tonight is what it means to be young rye
i have these are yeah
let the fires be started we're dancing
for the restless and the brokenhearted
unbelievable movie that soundtrack is
one of my favorite things in the whole
world i
absolutely agree it's an amazing [ __ ]
soundtrack you are wonderful
singular i love that very very like
walter hill right mm-hmm
very singular flick that like even was
weird when it came out
but still weird today and as much as
like huh like that i grew up watching
you know in my house and my dad was bill
like we watched big wednesday
that's right we watched the warriors we
watched streets of fire
you know that this was my life your dad
was a classy tasteful man
you knew everything about movies and
music
yo-yoing it was that's true yes he was a
[ __ ] yo-yo master as well
the yo-yo master who the [ __ ] say i
know exactly
but what a great skill to have man and
like especially if you're a guy running
a store
because at the very end of the day you
could always be like if you know the
customer's always right you could always
be like well check this out and [ __ ]
rock a yo-yo you want to read a company
what we're doing now
is i'm sorry to cut you guys up but
basically what we're doing is private
signings we're saying we're going to
send the stuff
to their personal home sign the stuff
send it back to golden apple and you
guys can buy
pre-signed stuff with a certificate of
authenticity that proves that it
happened and all that good stuff
then we're trying to throw in some fun
stuff like a zoom call
some golden tickets where you can win
some stuff um
you know we're doing which gerard way is
coming up we're going to be doing
something with him
taboo from the black eyed peas is doing
a werewolf by night comic book we're
gonna do something with him
oh [ __ ] marvel we're trying to make him
doing a marvel werewolf by night
yeah yeah they got some black eyed peas
wow
um you know so things like that there
are a lot of
great creators that are still out
promoting comics writing comics creating
comics
just like yourself um you know obviously
we can
always do something with you kevin
anytime or mark if you're
doing some more stuff where do folks go
find the information how can they find
out about the carpenter signing and the
other signings
funny you should mention that no uh
goldenapplecomics.com that's the easiest
way to
to find us or on any of our social media
but the other thing i want to tell you
guys about and if i can just spend
two more minutes because please i know
you got a date and it means you're
getting lazy
you're keeping me from guaranteed sex
with a woman i've had
i know sex with many times but go ahead
that's all right it's important guys
it's really important so
it's not all honky dory in the world of
comic book retailing i might have
you know in the course of our
conversation may make it look like it's
amazing and everything's hon
you know great but really a lot of
stores are gonna be going out of
business
um can i ask you a question about that
there was a moment in the beginning of
the pandemic where i actually talked to
walter back east where i was like well
is it time to stop and he was like what
do you mean i was like you know we've
had 22 good years
and yeah a lot of stores are closing
maybe now
go out like you know not in debt and
with a win and the only thing is like
well
kovit allowed us to shut down and he he
voted against and not even because he
wanted the job he's just like you can't
it's an institution he's going as long
as you're not losing money like you
should keep going but i wanted to ask
did you have a moment where you guys
were like
maybe is this the end are we done
absolutely i mean
you know three months being closed i
think in the first couple weeks
i that was the first instinct yeah
well we had a great run you know i i
carried on this legacy for my pops
i tried my hardest guys but this one
beat me today yeah i mean nobody could
have seen
[ __ ] covert coming so nobody would be
like you dropped the ball it's like no
shame in it once in a hundred year
[ __ ] right
that's killed huge businesses and and
corporations so like
mom and pop shop what's happened is like
comic stores
all the local mom and pop stores like if
they had an online presence or social
media presence or a website
that's what they relied on that's what
we rely on or old school
like phone banking like i called every
customer my mom did my wife did
just love bombing the deaf like hey
we're still here we'll get you your
comic books
you know we did it everything we could
to connect with our customers
i started doing online games and this
crazy wacky
you know game shows on facebook and
instagram live and i sort of adapted
a lot of people do live sales and you
know if you're in it to win it
you're going to find a way to make it
work no doubt a lot of stores
it's not that they're not in it to win
it they just don't have the tools the
resources the customers they're in
obscure parts of the country or the
world and they just don't have the foot
traffic and with a covid world
they're just they're out of sorts a lot
of people are [ __ ]
a lot of people a lot of stores are
going out a lot of stores will continue
to go out because like
if you think about it think about your
personal you know finances
your landlord gave you some extra room
your
your mortgage gave you some extra room
you know that's no different than what's
going on in the retail world
well guess what it's been six months and
now
they're going to start asking for their
money yeah exactly
and so i could see a lot of stores
saying well we tried we tried to getting
an sba loan or whatever we could do
nothing came through we're [ __ ] so
what we're doing is
i'm on the board of uh a new initiative
a new campaign
did you guys remember back the comeback
say it again what is it
there was something called back the
comeback a few months ago yes yes
they gave out t-shirts and stuff that
was like the first initiative to try to
save complex stores from the covid world
2.0 just launched and it's called give
uh i'm sorry give comics hope and it's
give
givecomicshope.org correct
and so basically what's happening is all
the publishers
creators retailers fans
are coming together to help save the
comic book industry
and what they're doing basically is
donating
so everybody's got a collection right
you have
tons of [ __ ] i see your podcast mark
come on you have a lot of [ __ ]
i have a lot of [ __ ] everybody has comic
books cgc
signature stuff posters autograph stuff
action figures whatever we got right i'm
not saying
give it all to charity i'm absolutely
not saying that but
if you can afford to just give a few
things
where there's something called drive for
five where they're asking for five items
you basically send it in to either this
one guy handling
the ebay auctions and there's another
person handling heritage
auctions and all the money goes to comic
book stores through the [ __ ]
foundation which was started you know
several months ago to help complex
stores um remember jim lee
drew 60 yeah yeah we had him on the show
on the show i know you guys have fallen
you guys are falling pretty far you had
like jim lee benefleck and like
me you guys are slumming it a little
right now oh man
you're real you're for your comics
royalty believe me i [ __ ]
appreciate the the few moments i have to
talk about this stuff
you know in the state of the industry
but basically there's a lot of
not golden apples out there or not you
know people are a little smaller that
just
need the [ __ ] help right now like
everybody needs help to stay alive even
we need help
you know and if you guys can you just
tell your
you know fans your you know the
customers in your comic book store
people who listen to your podcast or
follow you guys on social media
to say look i got a ton of [ __ ] in my
room and instead of going
and trying to sell it on ebay give it
to give comics hope dot org you know
that's the easiest way to do it you
could even sell
yourself on ebay and in in the listing
you can say i want to give a percentage
to a charity and just click
give comics hope um so that's really
what we're here to talk about
you know is just the comic industries
had his ups and downs since cobit
started
there's some great stuff like the
collector market being so strong and so
amazing and these varying covers we're
all doing
are just selling out and you know the
peach momokos and all that kind of crazy
stuff but
underneath it all the local comic store
in your town is
is probably hurting and if they're not
in la or new york or some
you know major you know place like this
and
they need your help and and we all need
to help them i'm helping them i'm
sending in like [ __ ] signed by stan lee
i think i have some stuff signed by you
guys
i have some of the iron bob exclusive
pops and things like that that i'm going
to send you know
whatever i can do to help i want to help
everybody succeed because
six months from now a year from now 10
years from now we want comic book stores
to be alive right you want
the secret stash to be there you know
you don't want to get that phone call
from your guys saying dude is this it
yeah are we out did we have a good run
like [ __ ] that we didn't
we did 40 years we want to do another 40
years right [ __ ] hey man that's the
goddamn spirit if uh
let me say i got some stuff to donate
can i give it to you
you could give it to me and i'll send it
in because i know that's like a hassle
for a lot of people
it's just you're the closest dude i know
but i i
got like bro the arms a set of arms that
i wore as the bratzy and yoga hose
because it could be like props
oh props are the best i have uh you know
what i have i have the red tornado mask
i don't know if you did that episode oh
from [ __ ] supergirl
yeah that guy's a customer and he came
in one day with with the actual
like cowl that he wore
from the red tornado was like here i'm
going to give it to you
and i've just saved it and i want to
give it to charity i got to
i got something to donate um zack snyder
gave me um from the watchmen
the dirty comic that the tijuana bible
the tijuana bible well remembered
so that would be something that somebody
would definitely
whatever you can you know feel
comfortable getting rid of that could
could generate something i got some i
got some good [ __ ] man some like good
like oh [ __ ] i got a hat the justice
league signed by every [ __ ] actor in
it
somebody would buy that right i mean
that's the thing like people send me
[ __ ] all the time i have so much stuff
that i
just i never paid for so they cost me
anything and it's worth money
and collectors out there want it so if
you're a collector
and you're listening to this go to the
ebay auctions go to the heritage
auctions bid it up
buy some [ __ ] but also think about
giving some stuff
and where do we send them again that
email at the the
web address givecomicshope.org
all the givecomicshope.org excellent and
that's where you can donate as well at
that website
that's right uh one of the big uh guys
in our industry bill shane is
who used to work at diamond he was a big
wig of course yeah
he was also a retailer before that and
he's just
just such a i would say a mensch
legend in our field yes absolutely he
started this
and he's been retired for years he has
no reason to do this
except for the fact that he loves the
complex world and industry
and wants to see it survive and so he
got together
so many people i mean i've heard robert
kirkman donated a bunch of amazing
original
walking dead pieces he keeps telling me
all this stuff that's been donated
and basically my part in this is is this
is is to reach out to customers and
influential people like
you know youtube guys who could spread
the word for us
and so you know i i hope
a year from now five years from now we
look back on this and
everybody's cool and we got complex
stores in your local neighborhood
and and the publishers are okay and the
printers are okay and the distributors
are okay
and and we just got through this [ __ ]
because this is
[ __ ] up guys yeah it's it really has
exposed how precarious the whole [ __ ]
thing
was man like [ __ ] it's coveted has
turned out to be kryptonite for a lot of
things but
for comic book stores particularly for a
lot of retail outlets
so it's you're doing the lord's work
number one man
because this is important this is
without comics we got no bedrock for all
the other [ __ ]
people do enjoy right now that's where
the magic begins on the [ __ ] page
and the magic usually begins in a comic
book store some kid some adult walking
in there for the first time going like
what this is it like i've never i had no
idea this world existed
so you're doing the lord's work keeping
that uh hope alive man
give comics hope dot org
i'm gonna collect a bunch of [ __ ] and
get it to you and you can get it too
we'll get the golden apple or figure out
a way to you know i can come to you
whatever
done service if you need to use that
you're not far from me i could bring it
down or you could come up but let me ask
you
let me at this ain't even a question
more for suggestion are you allowed to
use that back lot
where people park and [ __ ] like i
remember for the gallery in 1980
at one point we we had a party didn't it
like
yeah so isn't that what we did right
after covet started
after the first month went through we
started doing
curbside pickup in the back parking lot
i got a pop tent signs
i put spiderman out there you know i got
a spiderman yeah you got that giant
spiderman statue
you autographed it tom holland
autographed it stan signed it
you know it's an impressive piece and i
have it out there in the back parking
lot we did that for about
two months and then finally we got to
open so we've been open ever since
limited hours at golden apple but we you
know
we're doing our part to give back to the
community that's that's been so good to
us over the years
but for uh rye for a signing event you
could probably
do it out in the parking lot because
you're outside
[ __ ] like that i mean i wouldn't risk it
with john carpenter because he's like
eleventy hundred and stuff
yeah not really doing that but for you
know younger
artists riders whoever to [ __ ] or people
who wanna promote stuff
there's still a way to do it there is in
that parking lot like you know and be
outside and [ __ ] but the window window's
closing because
the fall is beginning i know right but
uh yeah it'd be
it could be fun like doing a little
parking lot event
it was it's it's so close it's and it's
kind of
like safe the parking lot back there and
as much as you really protected
from the street and it's a back alley so
there's no heavy traffic
so yeah you could that could be like a
fun area to actually have a
signing vent be outside and stuff i mean
traditionally like
a free comic book day that you guys set
up out there right
we set up out there the butcher shop
next door has a
as a grill they're doing burgers the
coffee shop next door
is doing their thing so you know we make
it a community event
um so maybe we can do something like
that so
you know if either one of you or anyone
listening has a cool
i'm volunteering i volunteer myself you
could probably get way more famous
people but i volunteer myself for a
thing
well you could probably get way more
famous people to do your show than me
but i appreciate you having me on so
we'll see you we'll see who we can get
together we'll see who we can
um so close some strengths for you so
glad you're keeping
not only keeping the head above water
for golden apple itself but
going out of your well a way to help
other [ __ ] retailers man that's
like let's be honest most retailers
don't give a [ __ ] about other retailers
for you to give a [ __ ] about the comic
book marketplace not just your personal
space
but the comic book marketplace in
general you you're a goddamn
you're as you said before a mensch my
friend
doing a good thing kevin thank you mark
um
basically you know it's it's not good
for anybody
look if you were running a fast food
restaurant and and [ __ ]
jack-in-the-box
and carl's jr go out of business that's
not good for
mcdonald right that's bad for everybody
if the big guys are all going out of the
little guys
the competition goes away
everybody's screwed so the rising tide
lifts all ships
i want i want everyone to to survive
this i want everybody to
you know do what they can to try to sell
online in the interim
but really put the stake in your store
the store is the community the store is
is the lifeblood of the industry you
know that where the subscribers that
come in every week
and touching those comic books and
collecting them
in bags and boards and boxes you know
that's that's what we do
that's we've always done and that's what
we hope to continue to do so thank you
guys for giving me this platform to talk
about it
and uh you guys rock i love you guys i
hope to see that that uh
masters of the universe at some point
next year man 2021
it's [ __ ] dope and then we're doing
books too
so i'll be in for a signing for those
this is the next thing you need to do
oh this believe me i've seen a lot of
people online going like can you do that
i was like i'm shocked they let me do
emails my buddy gave me this today as a
you know like a preliminary birthday
gift unfucking believable these super
seven figures
it's got it's not a plug that's not a
plug i don't even sell them in the store
that's just for me
when is the birthday when's the birthday
uh
october 8th right on man i'm pretty
happy birthday
so it's happy birthday in advance i'd be
belated 50th to you
and mark you're like 20 right i am 24
years 21.
turn the big kid just got my driver's
license
um all right tell your mom i said hi you
be good
keep fighting a good fight uh
givecomicshope.org ladies and gentlemen
correct thank you guys in golden
applecomics.com
you guys rock thank you so much enjoy
everything
and all yours yep
oh he froze there he is thanks ryan
excellent kid man and doing the lord's
work man
indeed like really you know
you don't have to [ __ ] you hurt him
it's hard enough being a retailer
on his own and he's been in business 40
[ __ ] years
over 40 years hard enough to keep your
own
ship afloat and here he is worrying
about other people's ships
i think he's right like it's it's not
it's not about competition at this
moment it's about how do we save an
industry
it's like the end of game of thrones
where it's like they want to see cersei
and they're like we gotta
get together because the [ __ ] white
walk
[Music]
yes i got real into my metaphor i'm like
no
no it's like game of thrones let me
explain to you because well like it's
not like that at all
it's in fact it's like anything where
people team up to survive
right it's more like you know we gotta
we gotta take on thanos before he snaps
his [ __ ] fingers exactly and so we
gotta like unite the [ __ ] warring
tribes and let's go
down exactly i don't know i was thinking
like oh man i just discovered the
ultimate metaphor
hot take hey did you ever hear this game
of thrones
um there that's it man normally we do a
q a but as previously
mentioned tonight is what it means to be
young
[ __ ] let the rebels begin let the
fires be started
we're dancing for the restless and the
brokenhearted
um thanks for hanging out with us here
man what a [ __ ] show we covered a lot
of ground
299. i know who knew next
next week next week we end it three yeah
that's it
i'm ending all my like we're taking a
page out of mark's book
and we're done that's it guys 300 we did
it then we start a new show
we do and then we give them a number
that we hit and then stop that and start
new things so wait we're just going to
reboot ourselves like always
yes like chapter seasons should have
been that
well um there it is when uh when does
your last battle start go up
um oh god i don't know it's not for
another couple of months galactica
galacticas we record the finale probably
next week
then the plan is after that a tv movie
they made
and then i don't know what happens but
right now the the broadcast date is word
about episode 12 or 13 of the season so
there's another 12 more episodes this is
a mark's side project man
[ __ ] like when they go off and create
a super group
like it's mark and [ __ ] the stars of
battlestar galactica have their own
super group and [ __ ] i thought you were
going to be like yeah it's like your
gummar
yeah zuzumari goes and he [ __ ] that
podcast behind my back
and i'm supposed to live with it i just
gotta live with it so i go out to that
galactic cast
i'm pressing the button i'm like you're
a [ __ ] janice is a [ __ ]
what are you doing karen karen what are
you doing here
they called me a karen too because like
what the [ __ ] are you doing complaining
get out of here
uh galacticast go give it a listen man
go check it out where you get your local
podcast we got
side projects here hell yeah but as for
the main project we're done
that's it we're finished take it easy uh
episode 299
slam dunk in the bag in the can [ __ ]
put it up on the shelf frame that [ __ ]
it's a wall book ladies and gentlemen
it really is it really is we want a
sneeze guard book it
is just like this um i haven't felt his
sneezes in so long
it's been a it's been a hot minute we
want to thank ryan leibowitz coming on
talking
about uh uh give comics
comicshop.org and golden apple go
support them go to goldenapple.com
uh as well find a way to support your
local bookstore that too that's what he
was saying most of them also have online
portals
and now is a great time i think lots of
people during this covid
were like you know what's a comic i
haven't read before this thing
let me go let me go deep in the vault in
the library and read the thing i haven't
read and if you're one of those people
that's just like i also
invest in comics you just got some
inside [ __ ] dope from a comic book
real
retailer right there he told you they
ain't printing up enough books
so every book is becoming a [ __ ] wall
book man so if you get in
on pre-ordering and [ __ ] online and
whatnot
you can order multiple copies of a book
then
that book's going to be worth something
you could trade i mean that's what i are
you goosing or collectors marketing i
really like that
i can't watch it go guys here's what you
do wait for the lenticular cover to come
out then she has
that one then you get all of them the
more covers the better
um there it is folks we have no [ __ ]
show
without the guy standing to my left
beyond the sneeze guard
beyond the sneeze guard is it fresh like
a salad it's a sequel to be on the
rainbow uh
uh give it up for the the great mark
bernard
thank you sir um and thank you to jc
who if we had control of multiple
cameras you would see he's here run out
in front of the frame
and show him your reel seriously you got
to come over here he's been so busy
there he is look at him [ __ ] one man
little studio
little one man kabc over there that's mr
netflix
you know how netflix i got a bunch of
people working one guy
one guy and like he didn't put any fires
out but they're all manageable that's
true
good point they're still simmering
everywhere they are
not lapping at our feet and that's all
we care about um
thanks for hanging out man on a sunday
sunday afternoon
well now it's evening yeah what time is
it ooh we went long
long and strong i know my wife's like
you know your window's closing
down and get the friction on truly
thanks for being here we'll see you on
uh friday or saturday i'm pretty sure
it's friday yeah
for episode three we'll see you the
weekend for episode
300 of fat man beyond but for fat man
beyond today episode 299
i'm kevin smith i'm mark bernard tune in
next time
for 300 same fat time same fat channel
smodcast.com or youtube.com kevin smith
for the good of all cree and so say we
all were kind of forever
we got it all
you